So we'll talk a little bit about working with materials in Unreal Engine and if you're
unsure what materials are we'll dig into exactly what their role is inside of Unreal
and then after this section we'll jump into a little workshop where I'll show you actually
how to create a material.
So essentially what are materials in Unreal Engine and what is PBR?
So a material is essentially an asset that's applied to a mesh to control the visual look.
So if you see from this diagram here at the top maybe from the player's camera or the
viewer's camera we see some glass inside the editor.
Now the glass is reacting in a certain way, it's maybe causing a reflection, this is all
the job of the material.
So the texture wouldn't be causing the reflection, it'd be the glass material which is causing
reflection and then the material also has some properties such as how the surface should
react so in this instance we're going to be bouncing light off the glass because it's
reflecting this sunlight in this figure.
And then for figure two for example if we want chalk which is more matted and it's absorbing
a lot more of the light you'll see that it's not bouncing off the surface as much and so
we can actually set the properties of the material inside of Unreal Engine to get the
desired outcome that we want.
So the simplest form is we think of it as paint with various properties such as the
colour and the finish and the material defines how light interacts with the surface and it's
applied to.
So PBR is a unified lighting and shading system, it's a better approximation of light and
materials, physical interaction and hopefully you find it very intuitive and consistent
to use, it's physically accurate especially when you're working on these AAC projects,
it's very powerful in that respect and uses real world physical measurements.
So PBR is a combination of your material setup, what lighting setups you have in the scene
and also exposure.
So when we talk about PBR we'll talk about primary PBR inputs, material settings and
textures.
And so when we look at the PBR material setup and again we'll jump into the engine in the
next section just to actually create a material but to give you an idea when we open the material
editor we have a base colour, some form of base colour that we plug in and say this is
a blue material in this example.
We also can plug in a numerical value into a metallic value and a roughness value again
to say how metallic is this surface, how rough, how much is it absorbing light, how much is
it reflecting light and just controlling these properties give us a really powerful output
for our material setups.
So our base colour when we're plugging it into our materials is called an albedo map
which is a flat colour without any specularity or shading, it's linear RGB which is a vector
3 and values are between 0 and 1, avoiding a pure black which is 0 and pure white as
they don't really exist in nature, it's always going to be some variance of between
0 and 1.
When we talk about the metallic ranges it's a grayscale value that ranges between 0 and
1, most common usage is on or off so we either set metal on which is 1 or off which is 0
and when it's 1 it yields 100% specular reflection so you can see the transitioning value between
0 and 1 in the image below just to give you an idea of that.
When we talk about roughness, roughness is essentially a grayscale value that ranges
from 0 to 1 as well, it ranges from a smooth mirror-like surface from 0 so you can see
that on the bottom left hand side of our image here to a rougher matte surface which is 1
on the bottom right.
Unlike with metallic you're encouraged to fine tune the roughness between 0 and 1 so
just play from your senior albedo map which is your base colour going into your metallic
map and then dialing in your roughness is a good workflow to look at there.
There's supported texture formats, so Unreal can handle many different file formats, for
optimisation purposes it's best to work with PNG when using image texture due to its lightweight
file size and its ability to have transparency info when needed but you can use uncompressed
file types, BMP, Targets, PSDs, it's good to note that Targets, depending on how you
save them in your editing suite, they can have the alpha channels with Targets which
is useful, PNGs are more compressed however they can support alpha as well as mentioned
before.
You can also import JPEGs, DDS and HDR.
So a few guidelines to keep in mind when you're importing your textures, textures should always
be a power of 2, so 16 by 16 all the way to 8192 by 8192, just keep them uniform there
and textures don't have to be square as long as they are a power of 2, so 16 by 128 is
completely fine, just making sure they are following that previous rule as a power of
2 and textures can affect streaming and memory management, so you know making sure, depending
on your optimisation, if you only need a small texture that's on this one small object in
the scene, maybe don't import it as 8192 by 8192, thinking about the scaling of the resolutions
there will help with memory management and high frequency textures can cause anti-aliasing
artifacts so you'll see when you import textures you get a few settings to show you how it's
been imported, how it's been displayed, different MIPS and formats and all these kind of properties
you can see the difference between streamed and un-streamed as well in those two dialogue
boxes there.
So when we talk about texture pyramids which are MIPS maps and custom settings you can
set these directly in the material editor and also from the texture, and again we'll
be jumping into the editor in a second, but the MIPS value mode is in the material editor
there which you can change the setting for and then if you double click the texture from
the content browser you can actually change the texture group if need be there, so there's
a couple of ways to use MIPS maps.
When you're importing the textures you can use the import button to simply drag and drop
in the Windows Explorer so you can either go through the method of clicking import and
adding content to your scene or you can just drag and drop them directly into the content
browser and they'll import fine.
Textures are converted to the U assets like we said at the outset here and you can open
a texture in the texture editor with a simple double click so from your content browser
just double click the texture that you've imported and you'll get this window on the
right hand side and here you can change the compression settings which we were referring
to before if need to and you can also enable or disable the linear colour space, the sRGB
there.